good afternoon NDC thank you have you
had a good few days I have it's been a
blast and they have asked me to to come
along and close out the conference for
some of you those of you who were wise
enough to be here because there's some
strong competition in this spot by
talking to you about something that I
call the art of code now does anyone
recognize the language that this little
intro sequence here is written in logo
this is not only is this logo this is
original Amstrad logo from 1985 because
the first computer that I ever had was
this the Amstrad six one two eight it
was rubbish I mean it was brilliant
because I'd never had a computer before
but it had the games that it had were
all this kind of green screen and they
weren't much fun compared to the games
in the arcades and everything and you
couldn't do very much with it no modem
no dial-up no BBS or bulletin boards or
internet but what it did have on it was
this logo programming language and logo
got me hooked because using logo I could
make the computer draw pictures and that
was a big deal in 1985 because I'd never
seen like I could put things on that
screen using logo that maybe nobody had
ever seen on any screen before and I got
hooked on it and I got this this lovely
kind of you know feedback loop where I
liked it because I could make the
computer do what I wanted and every time
I did that I'd get this little thrill
and this rush and I'd go back and I'd
have another go and you know throughout
my entire career developing software and
designing systems that thrill for me has
never gone away and I hope for you all
you here as well you know you have good
days and bad days but you still get that
rush when you know all your tests are
green or when you you know you hit
monitoring and it's a hundred percent or
something just works and you're like I
did that I made that work and over the
last three days here at NDC London we've
had some
amazing brilliant people telling us how
to solve useful important problems how
to design scalable services deployment
strategies information security the
ethics of artificial intelligence and
machine learning I'm not going to talk
to you about anything useful because I
am going to talk to you about art and
all art is quite useless says Oscar
Wilde now I don't entirely agree with
this quote I like this quote a lot
better the function of art is to hold a
mirror up to nature and if we want to
use art as a tool to explore and
understand the world around us we can
hold a mirror up to it but before we can
do that we need to invent to the mirror
and that is where science and technology
and engineering come in because for
centuries we humans have built machines
and tools to help us explore and
understand the world around us we've
created scanning electron microscopes
that have allowed us to see things like
this this is shards on the eyelid of a
beetle it's been there the whole time
and nobody had ever seen it until we
invented machines that could take
photographs of something that's only a
handful of micrometers across this is
crystals growing in a dish of soy sauce
this is the stems inside one strand of a
banana leaf this amazing beautiful
microscopic world we had never ever seen
and we've sent machines and cameras and
telescopes and people into space and
we've looked back we've seen you know
our planet Earth rising above the moon
we've looked back from beyond the rings
of Saturn this is us down here this is
the pillars of creation this is six
thousand light-years away in the
Horsehead Nebula and until we invented
machines to show us these things nobody
had ever seen it and within the last
thirty years maybe we've started
exploring another hidden world that's
been there the whole time until we
developed the machines that allowed us
to go in and see it and play around with
it it's a world of mathematics and
information throughout the 1970s there
was a guy called Martin Gardner who
wrote a column for Scientific American
magazine about mathematical puzzles and
curiosities and certainly the most
influential of his columns he ever
published was this one October 1970
where he described something called
Conway's Game of Life created by an
English mathematician called John Conway
now as games go Conway's Game of Life
does not look terribly exciting it is a
game for no players played on an
infinite board and it has four rules the
rules of life the first rule each of
these cells on our grid can either be
living or dead if a cell has zero or one
neighbors it will die of loneliness if a
cell has two or three neighbors it
survives to another generation if a cell
has four or more neighbors it's like
being in London it dies of overcrowding
or it moves to Germany I don't know but
it's not there anymore and finally and
this is where it gets a little bit
spooky weird if a dead cell has exactly
three neighbors it will come back to
life and that's it
that is you now understand everything
that there is to understand about the
rules of Conway's Game of Life
now when Martin Gardner's article was
first published 1970 very very few
people had computers and so they used
pens and graph paper to play the game of
life and they drew diagrams like this
now these these five shapes of what we
call the tetrominoes there are five
Tetris tiles and this shows you the
evolution of each of those shapes under
the rules of Conway's Game of Life but
you know looking at this it's like go
new Museum where they have the
butterflies pinned in a glass case you
can see what the butterfly looks like
but you don't understand anything about
a butterfly from looking at this kind of
representation it wasn't until we
started using computers to actually
simulate this stuff that we really
understood the behavior we were looking
at because these four patterns they all
stabilized quickly but this one over
here this is just gonna keep going
over and over and over
and once we could visualize things like
this exploring the game of life became
addictive people started saying you know
are there packings that will move across
the grid and just keep going are there
limits is the game bounded or is it
infinite this was one of the first
shapes this is known as a glider repeats
itself every six generations and it just
keeps crawling across the grid forever
and once we realized bladers were
Possible's people started looking for
more and they found hundreds of these
shapes spaceships they call them these
incredibly elaborate beautiful creations
that just glide across this grid driven
by four simple rules and that's it one
of the earliest questions that came up
in the game of life can you create
patterns that will grow infinitely it's
a guy called Bill Cosby was a founding
artificial intelligence researcher and
computer scientist some of you may have
heard of and his team at MIT in the
1970s they created something absolutely
wonderful they created a thing called
gospel glider gun now what the glider
gun is is it's a stable configuration
and every 27 generations it creates a
glider and since these gliders streaming
out across the grid and gossip esteem
discovered another you know lots of
configurations while they were exploring
this they also discovered this thing
here which was called Villita
now we have a glider generator and we
have a glider consumer we can generate
signals and we can destroy signals we
have one and we have zero and if we have
one and 0 we have binary logic and we
can use that to create logic gates so
this thing here is a NAND gate built in
the game of life these little
highlighted cells are our inputs now
what we're going to do first of all
we're going to start the circuit running
and then we're going to say ok we're
gonna take that blocker out so that our
input a becomes true there we go
a is now switched on we have no output
signal we only have one input let's flip
the inputs what happens if we switch B
on will be as on but we still have no
output signal because this is a NAND
gate in order to get an output signal
here we need to enable a and
be we switch on both of those inputs we
switch on our circuit and there we go we
have a NAND gate now the brilliant thing
about this is that if you have logic
gates you can make circuits and if you
can make circuits you can create
computers and if you can create
computers you can run programs including
this program that you may have heard
about a little while ago it's a thing
called John Conway's Game of Life and it
goes a little something like this
now Conway's Game of Life is just one of
a whole category of systems that exhibit
very very complex behavior based on what
looked like very very simple rules
simple inputs you've probably heard of
this thing called the butterfly effect
it's a term we get from a branch of
science called chaos theory the idea
that weather prediction is impossible
because if a butterfly flaps its wings
that input is gonna change the output
and you're gonna get hurricanes instead
of sunshine in Tokyo two weeks later or
something and over the last few decades
mathematicians everywhere have started
studying systems in a different way for
a long time
maths was only interested in problems
you could solve give us the solution if
you can't give us the solution this
problem is not interesting we're just
gonna go and find something else to look
at but mathematicians kind of embraced
this this whole at different school a
different way of thinking we created
imaginary numbers now the basic rule of
an imaginary number we have this number
I and in the natural world negative
numbers don't have a square root 2 times
2 is 4 minus 2 times minus 2 is also 4
so how do you get what times what equals
minus 4 well nothing it doesn't exist
and mathematicians go no problem we'll
just make something up we'll invent I
it's an imaginary number and I squared
equals minus 1 and they just this is
where the rest of the world goes you
can't do that and mathematicians go we
can do anything we want it's an
imaginary we don't we don't care but
then once they've developed this and
they've come up with a rigorous set of
mathematics around it you can do some
really interesting things with it now
this thing here zero point eight plus
one point two I I hang on a second give
me one second there's a bunch of slides
of gonnna stare and this is not making a
huge amount of sense that yet no wicked
will get we get we get one slide is
missing right now this number here no
point eight plus one point two I this is
what's called a complex number a complex
number is like a project plan it has a
part that is real and it has a part that
is imaginary and it is very difficult to
predict what is going to happen next
once these things get involved now there
is a whole study of systems and the
behavior of systems that we can talk
about this thing here is called an
Argand diagram and the the blue bit is
imaginary the red bit is real so not
point eight over there on one point two
I plot it up there and this way we can
plot numbers in in complex mathematics
in this this kind of space
and we can do arithmetic with these
numbers just like you used to do in high
school so we take point eight plus one
point two I you just expand the numbers
out as you go and you multiply and all
you need to do is remember that anywhere
you have two blue numbers multiplied
together the result is going to come out
negative it's gonna come out backwards
so this one point two times one point
two I will you square them and then you
stick a minus on the beginning and you
take negative complex inputs you get
complex numbers out the other end now
what's really interesting is when you
start studying the behavior of systems
that are driven by these let's take a
really simple function e we're gonna
take some real number X so we're back in
in ordinary mathematics and every
generation X is gonna go to X plus 1 so
one two three four and you can already
intuitively see you know how this system
is gonna behave you can can't be
confident you understand its behavior
all the way up to infinity let's try
another one so if we take this example x
equals 2 minus X it's gonna go to there
not - - - - - not - - round and round
and round if we apply the same thing to
this complex number what we're gonna do
is we're gonna keep taking that number
and squaring it first time we square it
it goes to here we square it again goes
to here we square it again it ends up
over here and then over here and then it
disappears off to infinity we're gonna
move it ever so slightly and we're gonna
run the same sequence again this time
point six and it goes to here and here
and here and here but it doesn't escape
this time
it goes into this little kind of weird
almost circular orbiting pattern now
those two points are right next to each
other but they exhibit dramatically
different behavior when we iterate them
over and over again by squaring them and
squaring them and squaring them and
eventually this one disappears now the
first really rigorous study of these
kinds of systems was done by this guy a
Polish mathematician called benoit
mandelbrot and Mandelbrot was fascinated
by the mathematics of real life he had
this quote clouds are not spheres
mountains are not cones coastlines are
not circles a bark is not smooth not as
lightning travel in a straight line
now Mandelbrot had a brilliant job he
taught mathematics at Harvard and when
he got bored he went to IBM and played
on the computers because this is the
1970s when IBM had computers and nobody
else did so he would come up with these
you know wonderfully complex
mathematical ideas and then he'd go over
to IBM and spend a couple of months
playing around and simulating them and
then he'd go back to Harvard and you
know talk to his graduate students about
all this kind of stuff and he was the
first person to see the shape which now
bears his name it's his name was
Mandelbrot but everyone calls it the
Mandelbrot set and I know that I'm gonna
do that so let's just call it the
Mandelbrot set basically it took each of
these numbers in this grid and he said
we are going to square this and add it
to itself and square it and add it to
itself and we are gonna see whether it
stays on the grid or not and if it stays
on the grid
we are gonna color it in black and if it
disappears and vanishes off the grid
we are gonna color it in a different
color depending how quickly it what's
called tends towards infinity he started
off with these very very low resolution
renditions of this image but the one
that you're probably used to the one
that all of us have seen is this the
Mandelbrot set now the astonishing thing
about this from this incredibly simple
mathematical rule there is an infinite
amount of complexity we're going to take
a Mandelbrot set here and we're just
gonna start magnifying and we are gonna
start zooming in and when we get to
around about here we're gonna say that's
1 times magnification and we're gonna
keep zooming and zooming and zooming and
by the time we get about here that
original shape is now size of this
building and we are still zooming in
when we get to around about here that is
2 to the 21st Amana fication the
original shape is now bigger than London
and we are still zooming in and around
about now the original shape is bigger
than the United Kingdom and we are still
zooming in and we are still zooming in
and we can continue zooming into the
shape forever it never repeats it is
what's called self-similar which means
it resembles itself at different scales
but it never repeats exactly there is an
infinite amount of detail buried inside
this one shape and this has been there
the whole time nobody invented this we
discovered it now this the Mandelbrot
set some people have called it the
thumbprint of God now I'm not a very
spiritual person but I do play a lot of
computer games and I love that thing in
a computer game where you're doing
something silly that maybe isn't part of
the main campaign and you find that the
game designers left something there to
persuade you that you were supposed to
be here and you're on the right track
and this thing has been hidden in
mathematics since you know our universe
was created and no one ever saw it until
we humans we invented computers which
means taking lightning and sticking it
in a rock until it learns to think and
we invented advanced mathematics we
invented high-definition color displays
and rendering technologies all this kind
of stuff and this is what we found
something that was hidden there the
whole time nobody had ever seen until we
built the machines and the technology to
allow us to visualize it now in this day
and age just putting pictures on a
computer screen is not actually that big
a deal anymore this was from Tron which
was a movie Disney made in 1982 first
film to have completely
computer-generated sequences Tron did
not win the Academy Award for Best
Visual Effects it was disqualified
because using a computer to make a film
was cheating according to the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences they
changed their minds eventually and they
gave it a lifetime award but we've got
really really good at using computers to
simulate things luxo jr. was the first
completely computer-generated film 1985
Jurassic Park 1994 the first time we had
computer-generated characters on screen
with human actors and it looked
convincing you know it looked compelling
it became part of the story
a couple of years ago we had this guy on
our cinema screens don't who this is
because there's one bunch of people who
say that's Peter Cushing and he's my
grandfather and he's dead and you
shouldn't have done that and there's
another bunch of people going that's
grand moff tarkin copyright Lucasfilm
Entertainment 1978 we own him you know
and you know who is it is it the actor
or the fictional character it's
triggered this really interesting left
ethical and legal debate but the point
is we can put I saw a review of the last
Jedi the last door which says we've now
that living actors playing dead
characters and dead actors playing
living characters it's come full circle
thanks to computer technology and we're
at the point where we can do anything
you could turn to your computer and go
you know what I'm bored what would it
have been like if they'd made friends
with Nicolas Cage playing all the parts
and we can just do that now
now the reason we can do things like
this is that we have created computers
and algorithms that work on the same
principle as some of the the most
complicated firmware in our own brains
you ever rely on your back in a field on
a sunny day and you're watching clouds
and your brain is kind of filling in
shapes for you it's cloud looks like a
rabbit that looks like an aeroplane that
whenever there looks like a house and
you're running all of these pattern
recognition algorithms and filling in
shapes and recognizing things and one of
the things that we are hardwired to do
is to recognize faces now we've got very
very good we don't entirely understand
how they work but we can now create
something called a convolutional neural
network you build a whole stack of
layers of logic and you give it input
you say these are cats and these are
dogs learn and it goes away and it
learns and it learns and it learns and
eventually it creates an algorithm that
you can give it a photograph and it will
say with confidence that's a cat or
that's a dog now you know that doesn't
sound terribly difficult right I mean
how hard can it be to tell a difference
between a puppy and a muffin you know it
can be a lot harder than you think
but we're getting good at this but what
gets really interesting is when people
take the dog detection algorithm the dog
detector and they wire it backwards and
they say this is now a dog amplifier and
the Machine goes alright and then you
give it a picture like this and you say
amplify the dogs and the computer says
this is a horrible idea please please
please don't make me and you say neural
network find the dogs and enhance the
dogs and it goes
you're gonna regret this and you cannot
turn up the power maximum dog
amplification and you get stuff like
this either this is a whole new kind of
art that has become possible because of
machine learning that nobody had ever
even thought of before and the technique
that's used to do this is something
called deep dreaming came out of a
project in Google in 2015 it's really
unsettling isn't it because you're
looking at it and what's happening is
those same circuits in your brain that
we've learned to emulate in in hardware
those circuits are going dog no it's not
dog dog no it's not a dog dog and kind
of your peripheral vision is finding
patterns you recognize but then when you
look at them it turns out you've been
tricked and so you get the kind of very
very complex perception around what's
going on with it now this is just one of
a whole bunch of ways that people are
using modern technology and software as
artists to create new kinds of art I
wanna introduce you now to a guy called
Robert Felker who I met in Warsaw the
other week who's doing some really
really interesting stuff when I start a
new art work it's just an inspiration
you just have a feeling so between the
first ID and the end wizard
there's just the same feeling it's not
about the visual I'm not interesting in
what you see I'm interested in what you
feel I'm Robert my everyday job I'm a
flutter dev and project manager and I'm
also photo artists previously I wasn't
kind of locked by the tool I can do a
lot of stuff but only what the tool
permits me when I found the flutter it
opened the door inside me now I can
really push further
[Applause]
generative art is a lot of research like
a lot it's a lot of failure it's a lot
of failure finding the color finding the
form understanding the good behavior of
light what's really good with flutter is
the speed of the feedback
it's nearly instant
currently artists do not understand the
full potential of the tool when you
start further you start with material
design or you start with the iOS
component and you think this is flat but
this is just the the tip of the iceberg
now if you want to push then you start
to enter the photo engine and the photo
engine is like the juice of the cone
each time I start to cut
I just feel joy so some people are
painting so people are cooking I just do
flutter and photo in and this is an
example of one of Roberts works this is
a photograph he took in Tokyo at night
that he then used machine learning to do
a depth perception analysis to identify
from the photograph the depths of all
the elements in this and then use
software and tools to creatively rebuild
the photograph working in layers and I
think this is quite beautiful it's kind
of hypnotic and every time you watch it
loop through it reveals something new
and this is just one of hundreds of ways
that artists are using code to create
new kinds of artworks we've never seen
before but what if we stopped talking
about using code to create art and we
start talking about code as an art form
in its own right now this very famous
book one of the great text books or
volume set of text books in computing
science Donald Knuth's the art of
computer programming and we can debate
for a long time is programming an art is
it science is it engineering is it
typing is it you know now but I'm sure
many of you have reviewed code that came
from somewhere maybe somebody on your
team was was tired or out of that depth
with it or maybe you were just having a
bad day and you look back at it a few
days later and you're like I don't know
what this is it's not engineering it's
not art I don't think it's terribly
creative I wouldn't dignify it by
calling it hacking I have no idea what
this is but fortunately there is now a
safe space for this kind of
code and these kinds of programs and it
is the International obfuscated
speedboat contest the goals are to write
the most obscure C program to show the
importance of programming style in an
ironic way to stress compilers with
unusual code to illustrate some of the
subtleties of the C language and to
provide a safe forum for port C code I
just like to share some examples with
you so this was a black I think Jonathan
Mills contributed this this is the
entire source code for this program very
C programs here in the room today
you want to tell me what this does and
it's just code right there's only one
screen of it how hard can it be
let's just run it and find out because
you know why not we'll just run that to
make file and then we'll run it and
there it is
it's flappy bird running in a terminal
here's another one lynnium zoom out give
you a little bit of context so this code
actually generates and draws the
Mandelbrot set in a text window and it
does it in a relatively kind of compact
code base that's shaped like the thing
it dramas which i think is rather neat
now brevity is one of the objectives of
obfuscated code you want to do something
really surprising with a very very small
amount of code this is the entire source
code for a program by a guy called Oscar
Pulido gee if you copy and paste this
into your web browser it plays chess it
doesn't draw a chess board it plays
chess it is a chess algorithm
implemented in just under a kilobyte
including JavaScript HTML graphics
behavior logic engines all the rules of
chess and an engine that is actually
better at chess than me this thing beat
me in games is that much JavaScript now
there are some astonishing examples of
programs that do wonderful things with
very very small amounts of code but none
of them is quite as good as this one
this was submitted to the International
obfuscated contest by Simona syncovich
in 2005 and it was accompanied with
documentation saying if you compile this
using this
compiler it will print its own source
code there's nothing here this is an
empty file but that compiler had a quirk
that if you fed it empty input it would
create a C program and compile it that
produced no output and so he quite
rightly said this program prints its own
source code now the obfuscated C
competition when okay one very clever to
have a price three we're changing the
rules from now on all programs have to
have at least one character of input
otherwise they are just this program
completed again but this idea of a
program that prints its own source code
is something called a quiet the word
comes from from this book which some of
you may have read which is that's kind
of fascinating riff on mathematics and
recursion and fractals and poetry and
music and stuff and it turns out that
writing a program that prints its own
source code is actually surprisingly
hard now you're not allowed to just read
it from disk and printed that would be
cheating you have to generate the source
from within itself so let's let's write
one I don't write a coin for you now
using c-sharp so we need a class program
with a static void main method and then
we obviously need to write line the
class program and close the bracket and
we need to write line the static void
main and now we need to write line the
right line and then we need to write
line the bright line with the and you
very quickly get tangled up in oh this
is just kind of e strings all the way
down but every language out there has
quirks loopholes that we can exploit to
make it do things that it wasn't
supposed to do now in c-sharp there is a
feature called string templating so we
can define a string that looks like this
and we can put placeholders in it these
little things here say when you see an
argument put that in the string at this
point and then we are going to feed this
string back into itself as a placeholder
variable so that when it gets to that
bit it prints itself and it doesn't go
into an infinite loop what it does is it
prints itself it prints its own source
code and different languages have
different loopholes you can exploit to
make coins JavaScript coins are very
easy because every function in
JavaScript has a two string that prints
it so this javascript function
itself in JavaScript and ACMA script six
this is a coin and I didn't believe this
because that doesn't look like anything
so I ran it in a console and sure enough
that's the output that gets produced
when you run it but what's really
interesting this is an idea I got from a
guy called Leon BAM brick who wrote it a
great post about this is can you make a
coin in HTML now HTML like you know is
it a real programming language I'm not
touching that argument can you write a
coin in it well let's find out here is
some simple HTML source code title head
body couple of paragraphs and a link to
Leon's original thing on this and this
is what it looks like in a browser right
start breaking some rules so first we're
going to put some style on that says
display everything as a block even
things that are supposed to be invisible
this star will match everything we run
that in a browser and now we can see our
CSS our source code is coming through in
that browser now we're gonna put some
rules in let's say well before HTML we
want you to display this and afterwards
you displayed this now the slash HTML is
actually down here off the bottom of the
screen because it knows it has to draw
it but we haven't told it where to put
anything and the safety is off at this
point we have no idea no the browser is
like you're on your own kids have fun we
plug in a bunch more rules style here we
have to put a backslash to escape the
slash because the web browser is
actually running three different passes
it's pausing HTML it's pausing CSS and
it's pausing JavaScript and they're all
fighting over who gets to eat the next
bit of input and at this point if we put
slash style our CSS parser is going to
go yep I'm done and HTML is gonna choke
on the rest of this chunk here so we
have to escape it now we have before and
after tags now there's no way of
generating these we just need to go and
plug-in head body title anchor paragraph
and we get this now you'll notice that
down here we've got this a but we don't
have the href equals with the web
address we want to link to can we do
that using HTML and CSS oh yeah no
problem
if you see a with an href we want you to
take this attribute and put it into some
content and stick it in before the thing
and there you go
and the last thing that we're going to
do just to make it look nice
is we're going to put a margin on there
and change the height of the age
and there we go we have a web page that
actually prints its own source which is
completely useless and utterly pointless
but how many of you learned something
you didn't know about the ages here's
our parser when you were watching that
little run-through there look at some
more here is some source code who wants
to tell me what language this code is
written in si si si any other votes for
si well let's let's apply a C
preprocessor to it well take out the
comments include standard IOH main char
I mean that the formatting on this is a
little wonky but yeah this is this is
fine this is completely valid C code but
what happens if we apply Ruby syntax
highlighting and highlight the strings
because that looks to me like perfectly
valid Ruby code right
let's try running it and see what
happens so I'm going to take that
program poly coin see there it is and
now I'm gonna feed that program into the
GCC compiler and I'm gonna run it it's
got a warning but we're way past the
point where we care about warnings and
there we go that program prints its own
source code and now because why not we
are going to run the same thing through
the Ruby interpreter and we are gonna
get look at that it prints its own
source code now we're going to run it in
Python because we can and it prints its
own source code and now hey in for a
penny let's run it in Perl and see what
we get
and it prints its own source code again
and apparently it'll also do it in C++
if you can find an old enough compiler
this is a poly coin this is a program
that is valid in more than one language
at the same time and in this example it
always prints its own source code now
who would like to tell me what language
this program is written in well let's
break it down alright let's do some
syntax highlighting so we got system dot
console which is kind of like a dotnet
II kind of a thing right and then we got
this chunk here which is an XML
namespace we got a console dot log in a
for each in the lower case so that
smells kind of JavaScript T to me right
we've got an ADA textio procedure we've
got begin in capital letters which is
either COBOL or SQL it's definitely from
the 1970s and it lives in a bank and up
here we've got act 1 scene 1 enter Ajax
which doesn't look like any program I've
ever seen now this is an excerpt from
something called the or Robert Quine
it's a ruby program that creates a rust
program and the rust program creates a
scholar program and the scala program
creates a scheme program which said
Shakespeare all the way around the
circle 128 languages until you end up
with a RC program that creates a Rex
program that creates the original rust
program again this was written by a
Japanese developer called Yosuke and
though who
one of the contributors to the Ruby core
language and the fact that it exists at
all is astonishing this is what the
source code to that coin looks like
[Laughter]
which is also incredible and if you zoom
in on the end of the source code you'll
notice that the last four lines all just
say buffer for future bug fixes because
they don't want to mess up the shape of
the source you know now this is the most
astonishing thing about this all 128 of
those languages can be installed on a
win to Linux by going apt-get recs
apt-get Shakespeare apt-get TC so there
is a github actions continuous build
pipeline for this thing that whenever
changes to it are committed it runs them
through all 128 languages and tells you
whether it succeeded or not which I just
think is fantastic and you know weird
but I love the fact that we can do that
but let's backtrack a little bit in that
chunk of code we looked at there was
some C and there's some JavaScript but
there's also act 1 scene 1 & 2 Ajax now
that is an excerpt of a program written
in the Shakespeare programming languages
one of a family of what are called the
esoteric languages ISA Lange's and
Shakespeare is designed to let you write
computer programs that are also
Shakespeare plays this is hello world in
Shakespeare the infamous hello world
program now all variables in Shakespeare
have to be declared as the characters in
the play so we have Romeo and we have
Hamlet act 1 scene 1 that's a namespace
and a block enter Hamlet in Romeo this
is variable scope we are dealing with
right now and then the way variables
work in Hamlet is when they say nice
things they increment and when they say
insulting things they decrement so at
this point Hamlet is talking to Romeo
and Hamlet says you lying stupid
fatherless big smelly half-witted coward
you are a stupid as the difference
between a handsome rich brave hero and
myself speak your mind
that puts the letter H into Romeo and
then outputs it because H is the first
character in hello world the next chunk
here will print e and so on hello world
and Shakespeare is about three pages of
fairly florid prose which is fine
because it's Shakespeare and that's what
it's supposed to look like how about
this one can anyone tell me what
programming language this is written in
this is white space let's have a look at
that with syntax highlighting applied
white space is a programming language
that only cares about spaces and tabs it
ignores everything else it's brilliant
if you want to hide programs inside
other programs mix up your tabs and
spaces and you can put whitespace
alongside anything else this is hello
world in white space let's take a look
at the hello world souffle now this is a
programming language called chef and
chef is designed for writing programs
that are also recipes now 72 grams of
haricot beans a hundred 1 X 108 grams of
lard 111 cups of oil you know 33
potatoes it's a valid program but would
you like to eat this souffle you know
and so somebody called a guy called Mike
worth looked at the chef's programming
language and when challenge accepted I'm
going to write a hello world program
that's actually a sensible recipe you
can make in your kitchen and he came up
with the hello world cake with chocolate
sauce now I think this is brilliant if
you compile this on a computer it says
hello world if you compile it in a
kitchen you get an edible cake with a
kind of chocolate sauce ganache that you
can pour over the top of it but the
thing I think about this that's
beautiful is if you didn't know about
chef you'd think this was just a recipe
it fits so well into two different
domains of human creativity that from
one you'd have no idea that it also
worked in the other one I'm going to
show you how to square a number in a
programming language called Pete that is
how to square a number in Pete
Pete is named after the Dutch artist
Piet Mondrian and Piet is a graphical
language where the instruction set is
dictated by what happens when you cross
from one color into another every Piet
program starts with an instruction
pointer in the top-left travelling
towards the right traveling due east so
what's actually happening here is when
we cross from light blue to dark green
that says input a number prompt the user
and put that on the top of the stack
when we get to black turn the
instruction pointer through 90 degrees
when we cross from green into red that
means whatever's on the top of the stack
duplicated when we cross from red to
yellow multiply top two numbers off the
stack multiply them put the product back
on the stack when we cross from yellow
into red that is output whatever is
currently on the top of the stack omit
that to standard out when we cross white
that is a no operation we reach the end
of the grid we turn right again and then
we follow this blue instruction certain
till we end up with black on all sides
which means you have reached the end of
the program please hold so that's a
completely Turing complete language
whose instruction set consists of areas
of light and shade and the transition
between colors this is hello world in
Piet one of many many examples but you
could hang this on the wall in your
house and somebody could come in and
take a look at it
they'd have no idea they were looking at
hello world they just think you like
kind of slightly weird 16-bit art you
know the Windows 3.1 school of
Expressionism now we've talked so far
about this whole idea of you know using
we've talked about using code to create
art we've talked about code that is art
and over the course of MDC you've
probably seen a couple of speakers here
doing live demos which are you know the
the tightrope the high wire act ooh the
death-defying circus thrill of the
technology industry because someone is
coding something on a laptop live and it
might work and it might not work and
there's always this element of kind of
risk and then it works and it runs like
yeah and you got a big round of applause
but generally as an industry we don't
like that you know we like consistency
we like reproducibility we like
automation we like being able to do the
same thing over an
over and over again if you've ever
worked in a place where there is a
server under a desk or maybe in a rack
somewhere that's running Windows 2003
Small Business Edition and you're not
allowed to touch it
do not put Windows Update on that or the
payroll will stop working on pain of
immediate gross dismissal you know and
we have a name for these kinds of boxes
that everyone is frightened to touch we
call it snowflakes snowflake servers
snowflake processes it's completely
unique but if you go out in the snow and
you pluck a snowflake out of a blizzard
and you watch it melt on your hand you
have just been part of a performance
that will never ever be repeated
anywhere your participation in that has
created a unique human experience that
nobody else will ever understand or be
part of and maybe we can do the same
kind of thing using code this guy here
is Sam Aaron and Sam is the creator of a
programming language called Sonic pi was
anyone in the last talk in this room
yesterday where Laura did her talk about
programming with music and she was
showing us had a program write computer
programs whose output is not text or
graphics it's music and tones and sounds
and melodies and she ended up by you
know doing this this wonderful kind of
layering thing because sonic pie is a
live coding music synthesizer I'll give
you a very quick demo of how sonic pie
works which I'm not gonna live code for
you because I don't want this to get too
meta
now when you start sonic pie it gives
you a prompt and you say play this note
and it plays that note now sonic pie
runs all your instructions in parallel
unless you tell it not to imagine if
JavaScript if you want things to happen
one after another you have to put sleep
instructions in and say we want to
introduce some kind of delay to this and
where it gets really interesting is we
can go in and we can start putting loops
around our notes and our musical
patterns so we got 16 times do that and
we've got the world's least exciting
bass line going
so let's crank up the tempo a little bit
we're gonna say use beats per minute
240-foot all right we're getting
somewhere and we're gonna change it
because the sine wave is not a terribly
exciting noise we're gonna use a
built-in synthesizer here called Tex
Soares now this is interesting but where
it gets really interesting as you'll
have seen in Laura's talk yesterday is
when we introduce the concept of
something called a live loop now live
loops allow you to run multiple
components of your program so I'm gonna
put a light blue there around that
baseline and then I am gonna drop
another loop over the top of it
[Music]
the fizzbuzz now sonic pie is fantastic
it's enormous amount of fun to play
around with I've seen people do live
coding with multiple you musicians that
picture of the beginning was Sam on
stage with the London Philharmonic
Orchestra doing live coding in the Royal
Albert Hall and you know it's an
absolutely astonishing tool and just one
of the brilliant and creative ways that
we're coming up with to use code to do
fascinating and unexpected things but I
want to finish today I've talked you all
about all kinds of things that other
people did I want to finish by telling
you about something that I did now you
are probably familiar with the trope of
the rock star developer because we've
all read job advertisements from people
looking for a rock star senior front-end
rock star JavaScript engineer rock star
senior Java software developer this has
been endemic in our industry for years
and last year Paul Stovall put this on
Twitter he said to really confuse
recruiters someone should make a
programming language called rock star
and I had this experience because I
thought this is it this is my purpose
this is why I was put here because what
the world clearly needs is a programming
language that allows you to write
programs that are also bad 1980s
heavy-metal songs and so rock star was
born a dynamically typed Turing complete
programming language for creating
computer programs that are also song
lyrics heavily influenced by the lyrical
conventions
of 1980s hard rock and pala balance now
Rockstar was created in a bar as a joke
that will become important shortly sad a
bar with a laptop and a beer and
thinking
could you make a language where rock
songs could compile to something now I
used to work in VB script and Perl a lot
and I've done work in Ruby so I'm used
to languages which try and you know
borrow a lot of elements from natural
language and incorporate them into
programming syntax so I thought all
right first of all if you were write
songs in it there's more than one way to
do it like the Perl idiom attempt Tony
you know so HelloWorld in rock star is
say hello world or scream or whisper or
shout these are all syntactically valid
programming requires variables and
assignment now you're probably used to
in x equals five var my string the
message now we don't need int because
rock star is a dynamically typed
language we are going to take those out
we don't need semicolons on the end
because if JavaScript can live without
them so can we now the equals sign in
the middle how do you sing that and
those you know let's just put is X is
five my string is hello world
the message is flutter rocks because I
forgot to update that that should say
NDC rocks now there's this ongoing
debate about casing you've had one of
those arguments longer than an hour
about Pascal case versus camel case
versus get bad case versus underscore
case and I shall Douglas Crockford the
guy created JSON give a talk two years
ago where he said we have all these
stupid arguments what we want are
variable names with spaces in them well
guess what when you're inventing a
programming language in a bar you can do
anything you like
so Rockstar has variable names with
spaces and it's not a complete
free-for-all there are three kinds of
variables simple variables work like
they do in JavaScript and Ruby common
variables have to start with my you're
the an a and proper variables need
capital letters so we can write programs
about dr. feelgood and black Betty and
Billy gene and all these you know great
characters who inhabit the world of rock
and roll
now initializing variables we normally
do with numbers fizz is three buzzes
five the limit is 100
I didn't want to do this because it
doesn't sound terribly metal really and
I thought how can you define a numeric
literal without having to use digits in
your source code and I had this idea
what if we take the lengths of the words
modulo 10 and we treat those as digits
so ice is 3/5 the limit is a love-struck
Ladykiller one that's 10 10 modulo 10 is
zero zero we've got three we've got five
we've got 100 without having to put
digits in our source code it works with
floating-point numbers as well and C
decimal PI 3.14159 and JavaScript var pi
equals we're kind of almost you probably
got something close to that back out
because hey JavaScript right in rock
star my heart was ice a life unfulfilled
waking everybody up taking booze and
pills 3.14159265 3/5 easy right you
gotta have to do arithmetic right now we
have these common you know ways of
talking glitch how much is it I the
total is the price with the tax well
what about the the net Anana that's the
total without the tax how many do you
need get me the quantity of the product
how fast were you going well speed is
the distance over the time you know we
have these things it's easy but this
mathematical convention also allows us
to write a girl with a dream a man
without a face the wings of the night
and a whisper over the water we need
comparison your love is a lie true or
false
well is it the whiskey ain't the answer
my heart is stronger than steel and my
soul is weaker than water as strong as a
lion as low as a snake we'd each
function syntax now the sort of
simplistic version here let's have a
function modulus it takes a number and a
divisor so those are input arguments and
while a number is as high as a divisor
put a number without a divisor into a
number and give back a number this is
how you implement modulus when your
building blocks are just addition and
subtraction and loops and stuff now this
works but we can do better right because
midnite takes your heart and your soul
and while your heart is as high as your
soul you
put your heart without your soul into
your heart and give back your heart now
at this point I'm about three beers in I
have a parody specification that is just
complete enough to implement fizzbuzz
and I have fizzbuzz in Rockstar I stick
this thing up on github and I'm just
like hey everyone introducing Rockstar
proposal for a turing-complete
programming language and I think this is
gonna be funny for like three hours you
know it gets 2,000 github stars
overnight it makes the front page of
hakkon news and just kind of starts this
buzz it made it into a Boing Boing
magazine Cory Doctorow wrote a thing
about it in there it made the front page
of Reddit people and reddit we're
actually saying complimentary things
about it the weirdest thing that
happened is I got an email from classic
rock magazine which is a real music
magazine that is nothing to do with
computers saying what's this Rockstar
thing that we keep hearing about so I
wrote a little thing for like an email
interview for them and I'm thinking like
this can't possibly get any weirder and
then people start filing issues against
my parody specification and I'm looking
at these and you know some of them are
just ideas like what a fool the numbers
go up to 11 and I'm like don't know that
arithmetics hard enough as it is but
some of them are like this undefined
behavior and I'm like what do you mean
there's undefined behavior why do you
care and they're like I built a rock
star compiler in Scala over the weekend
and it has edge cases like you did what
and within about a week there was a
Scala interpreter so I would have built
a compiler for in rust somebody had
built a rock star to Python transpiler
and the fascinating thing is all of them
had managed to do like 95% of it just
based on this random stuff I came up
with in a bar as a joke and some of it
makes no sense and you know if I'd known
it was ever gonna be real I'd of course
have done it differently but programming
is like that you know now I really liked
the idea of Dylan Beattie the creator of
rock star and I didn't think I'd done
enough work at this point to really earn
that and I also wanted rock star to be
you know scholar and Rustin and Python
are all very well but I want it to be
something accessible something
that anybody could just open up in a web
browser and write some Rockstar code and
see what it did and so this time last
year I basically spent about five
weekends we teaching myself how to build
compilers and parsers and meta-circular
evaluator x' and stuff and i built a
rock star interpreter in javascript
which is definitely the stupidest
dumbest thing i've ever done
and it's online and it is here it is at
code with rock star calm and everybody
here in this room is welcome to go and
try this put some code in there and you
will then be a rock star developer now I
just want to shout out one thing the
logo here in the top left I wanted to
borrow some like real over-the-top
access 1980s rock and roll heavy metal
influences and I looked at dudas priest
and Iron Maiden and Motley Crue and all
these kinds of people and then somebody
said have you thought about Microsoft
consumer products 1980 to 1982 and I was
like that is exactly what I want that
logo type is perfect so thank you
Microsoft for letting me recycle your
old logo be green now I do have some
certified Rockstar developer stickers to
give away here at NBC so come up
afterwards with your code with Rockstar
comm code on your phone and I will
certify you you will become a member of
the world's most prestigious developer
program but to end the talk today I'd
like your help in something now I showed
you some examples in there of like hello
world and Pete that just looks like a
painting and the chef hello world
chocolate cake that could just be a cake
and if you like the the test of whether
Rockstar really succeeds as a language
is can you perform a rock star program
and have people just think it's a bad
heavy metal song from the 1980s and so
with your indulgence I'd like to close
NBC and this talk by performing live
fizzbuzz in rock star
[Music]
takes your heart and your soul while
your heart is as high as your soon put
your heart without your soul into your
[Music]
give back your heart you remember the
fizzbuzz riff
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much in DC thank you for
coming thank you for your time thank you
for listening
who's going to pub gun if you thought
that was silly we got way more stuff in
store if you don't if you're coming to
pub gun I will be emceeing tonight we
got 12 amazing speakers lined up with
five-minute funny talks there are still
tickets on sale if anyone doesn't have
plans tonight
Pupkin oh if you are not coming to
PubCon thank you very much I will see
you somewhere out on the road have a
wonderful weekend
see you soon bye-bye
[Applause]